there are growing fears that a surge of
new infections could delay the
government's plan to lift remaining
lockdown restrictions on june the 21st
the number of new cases in england has
risen by 76
over the past week and while ministers
are hopeful that vaccinations have
broken the link between infections and
serious illness
downing street says that the government
needs more data before taking decisions
officials are drawing up a range of
options which could include a delay to
unlocking
or other measures such as requiring
people to go on wearing masks
well let's go live now to bolton where
sky sanjia choudhary
is outside a vaccine center and
first of all sadia government we
understand now considering
different options to lifting everything
on june the 21st
yes the first time we've heard about
this isn't it that there might be
some more restrictions even though
lockdown will officially
end on the 21st or that's the plan so
far at least and
these are things that are being
considered things like continuing to
wear masks
those sort of smaller restrictions
rather than the overall lockdown but you
know a lot of people are saying there's
not much of a difference because things
are open right now
gyms are open hospitality is open but
we're hearing suggestions that may be
working from home
will still continue beyond 21st but what
the government has said today is that
it's not off the table we're still
planning to open uh everything on the
21st but there are
some data to be monitored and that is
going to be monitored very very closely
and
you know things that the government will
want to look at are things like
the impact that the half term has had
with people
mixing a little bit more than the
traffic light system for international
travel and how that's done and of course
uh vaccine uptakes in places like bolton
where i am
and as you say you're in bolton one of
the recent pandemic hot spots there's
been a big push
on vaccinations there what's happening
now
well actually adam not a lot happening
here today i'm outside a vaccine center
which has just recently been set up and
i've been here i've been here for
just under an hour and one person that
i've seen has come out
and i spoke to him and he said that he
was the only person inside being
vaccinated and that there were
lots of people um wait waiting to give
him vaccines
you know i don't know if you can make up
behind me but once in a while someone
with
army fatigues will come out so an
indication that the army is helping
uh to do this i did see a delivery guy
come to drop off some food but other
than that it's been very quiet
a sense here that uh when we saw
cases rise as we did a few weeks ago
lots of new
vaccine centers were opened up very
quickly has to be said
here in bolton but now this uh this idea
this indication that there are
more vaccines here than people that are
coming forward to get vaccinated
initially we did see those long queues
if you remember outside the vaccine bus
in bolton
where lots of people came in that first
weekend to get vaccinated
but really with the weather like this
and with half term there's there's a
feeling that
most people are staying away from that
vaccine sites now either because they've
already had it or
because they you know they feel like
they've got better things to do
and so there's this uh there's this
complaint from neighboring blackburn and
darwin where
they've also got high cases of um covid
happening right now
but not enough vaccines and they're
imploring
for vaccines to be sent from bolton to
blackburn and darwin
so that they can make use of it here and
i've seen lots of i've been sent lots of
whatsapp messages from local councillors
here
who say that you know there's b they've
tried lots of ways to get people
to come and make use of the vaccines
that we've got in places like the
the building behind me um you know
anyone over the age of 18 can come and
get vaccinated i've seen messages being
put out on twitter
that if you haven't had a dose just come
turn up to one of these places as long
as you're registered with a bolton
gp you can get your vaccine but you know
here what's the feeling here on the
ground is that the vaccines are here
but not enough people to take them